der dienst von michael kloss hat eben
erst begonnen es wird kein schöner tag
werden
der 52 jährige hilft auf der korona
intensivstation im klinikum stuttgart
er informiert angehörige über den
zustand von menschen die hier liegen in
einem fall sieht es nicht gut aus
ein mann liegt im sterben er hat coop 19
die lunge hat versagt jetzt auch die
nieren kloss hat mit der familie
telefoniert sie soll abschied nehmen
können
es betrifft mich auch weil viele
patienten kenne ich jetzt schon seit
vielen tagen hier auf der station ich
habe sehr viel kontakt auch mit den
angehörigen und spreche mit denen ich
weiß was sie bewegt und wie die
verbindungen zu der gehören sind ja das
ist mein herz auch mit betroffenen aber
ich lass mich davon jetzt nicht leiten
über ein tun also es bewegt mich ich bin
auch ein mensch wie jeder andere auch
und deswegen versuche ich das auch ein
stück weit weg zu schieben ja
trotzdem berührt es mich ja weil ich
einfach teilhaben an dem was jetzt
gerade passiert dass menschen einen
wichtigen menschen verlieren
kloss der eigentlich wirtschafts coach
ist aber ehrenamtlich auch
krisenintervention safer kennt alle
gefühle allen schmerz doch er muss
sachlich bleiben die angehörigen haben
immer ein anspruch darauf sehr schnell
zu erfahren um was es geht um selbst
dann auch einzuschätzen und mit ihren
eigenen gefühlen auch zurecht zu kommen
aber wichtig ist dass die botschaft
schnell und ungefiltert nach möglichkeit
gebracht wird aber trotzdem so schonend
wie möglich an diesem tag sind 17 von 18
betten belegt der aufwachraum wird jetzt
auch mit intensivbetten aufgerüstet die
lage verändert sich täglich
sie wollen vorbereitet sein damit sie
schnell helfen können
die auslastung ist hoch wir haben hier
eine intensivstation voll belegt mit
kobe patienten am weitere
eskalationsstufen die wir phasenweise
schon nutzen müssen das jetzt machen wir
eine grenze sozialen des überlaufen und
könnten bei bedarf weiter eskalieren
dann aber um den preis von
einschränkungen anderen
behandlungsmethoden
kürzlich haben sie den ehemaligen
luftschutzbunker des klinikums als
lagerraum entdeckt dort wo sich früher
menschen in sicherheit brachten werden
jetzt masken schutzkleidung aber auch
technisches gerät aufbewahrt
das klinikum stuttgart ist das größte in
baden-württemberg 2000 200 betten 7000
mitarbeitende über 100.000 corona tests
haben sie schon durchgeführt bisher sind
sie gut durch die pandemie gekommen aber
menschen sind hier auch in verbindung
mit cupid 19 gestorben
dass es nie einen mangel gab das ist
auch sein verdienst
till sundermeier verantwortet den
einkauf des medizinischen sache darf so
heißt es im fachjargon wenn masken
antigen tests aber auch rasierschaum
oder tampons bevorratet werden müssen
in den regalen sieht es aus wie im
möbelhaus und immer er liebt sundermeier
überraschungen
vor allem ist es hauptsächlich dass die
ware die man immer gehabt hat vom
lieferanten dann auch ausgetauscht wird
durch ein ersatzprodukt dann verändert
sich größen in den einzelnen
verpackungen dann wo früher mal 50 drin
waren sind auf einmal nur noch 20 drin
und so verschiebt sich dann alles mit
allen folge prozessen seit wenigen tagen
weiß der 28-jährige auch das klinikum
soll ein im zentrum der stadt werden am
15 dezember soll alles stehen
vorausgesetzt der impfstoff ist
verfügbar
nur was wird dann wie gebraucht wir
wissen es noch nicht so genau weil noch
nicht klar ist wie ist der impfstoff am
ende des tages verpackt kommt der
beispielsweise in einer fertigen spritze
oder brauchen wir eine spritze wie muss
ich den impfstoff lagern oder muss nicht
lagern wie wird er geimpft also in einer
kleinen spritze oder in einer großen
spritze was man sicher schon merkt ist
dass der markt leergefegt ist für
klinikchef jan-steffen jürgen sinn ist
die impfung das thema der nächsten
wochen möglichst viele menschen in
kurzer zeit zu impfen
das ist die größte herausforderung wir
werden versuchen die aufklärung schon
als vor aufklärung digital mit tutorials
filmfreak wirklich als quetschen zu
unserer klaren aufklärungsbogen
auszugestalten und dann ist das am ende
ärztliche aufgabe das nochmal
abzusichern haben das verstanden haben
sie fragen ich fasse es noch mal
zusammen das würden wir möglicherweise
in unserer gesundheitsakademie machen
und es findet die in punkten
stock krisensitzung einmal in der woche
schalten sich oberbürgermeister das
polizeipräsidium die branddirektion das
gesundheitsamt aber auch andere
stuttgarter krankenhäuser zusammen
wie bedrohlich ist die lage in der
landeshauptstadt 7 tages incidence werde
zahlen werden ausgetauscht was könnte
auf die klinik zu kommen
operativ haben wir große notfallreserve
kapazitäten aufgebaut könnten bis zu 324
beatmungsgeräte in betrieb nehmen die
logistische herausforderung um runde der
personaleinsatz zwar vor der pandemie so
das ist ein fachkräftemangel gibt
jeder muss diesen mangel organisieren
die 49-jährige ist leiterin der korona
intensivstation
seit der ersten welle wissen sie hier
das künstliche koma und die sofortige
beatmung tun den menschen die hier
liegen nicht gut für die pflegekräfte
aber bedeutet das mehr arbeit wenn sie
in diese vollmontur arbeiten sie direkt
am patienten jetzt arbeiten haben sie
noch ein bisher an und eben schutzbrille
manche patienten haben sogar noch eine
infektion draufgesattelt da müssten sie
sich doppelt noch anziehen
schutzmaßnahmen und eben peinlichst
darauf achten dass sie hier nicht noch
kreuz infektionen herbeirufen
und es ist schon eine belastung
überwiegend liegen hier menschen über 60
doch es gibt auch jüngere einen mann 48
vier kinder haben sie gerade verlegen
lassen er muss an eine spezielle lungen
maschine
seine chancen sind nicht gut
wir arbeiten ja hier an diesem hotspot
und wir sehen natürlich auch die ganz
schlimm vorläufe sieht ein mensch der
mit einer klinik nie was zu tun hat sie
das vielleicht auch gar nicht so
und es gibt ja jetzt nicht jeden tag
bilder wie es in auf den stationen
aussieht und da ist es wahrscheinlich
die wahrnehmung eine ganz andere
an diesem tag sterben zwei menschen auf
der korona intensivstation
es ist kein guter tag im klinikum
stuttgart